my name is lauren price and i'm a
networking specialist customer engineer
at google cloud and today i'm going to
talk to you about the networking
concepts for cloud run that are helpful
to know for implementation security and
connectivity
cloudrun is a managed compute platform
that enables you to run containers that
are invokable via requests or events
cloudrun is serverless it abstracts away
all infrastructure management so you can
focus on what matters most building
great applications
cloudrun along with other google cloud
serverless services does not run within
a vpc
cloud run is a regional service meaning
services are deployed to a single region
but replicated across zones for high
availability
let's dig into the connectivity patterns
for the connectivity patterns we're
going to focus on ingress and egress
we'll start with ingress
by default when you deploy to cloud run
you're given a url that can be routed on
the internet the url will always be
resolvable on the public internet
however by default services refuse all
requests unless iam is configured for
the service ingress configuration and
authentication parameters can be set to
change access patterns and we'll dig
more into these settings when we talk
about security the next ingress pattern
is through a global external https load
balancer cloudrun can be configured as a
backend service to a load balancer
through a serverless network endpoint
group or neg for short
additionally with this option you have
the ability to configure a custom domain
for your cloud run service
cloud run services can be accessed
privately from your vpc through the use
of private google access or private
service connect when pga or psc is used
rather than clients needing an external
ip address or using a nat gateway to
egress to the internet
clients can route privately to the cloud
run service using either a google
provided vip for pga or a chosen rfc
1918 endpoint for psc directly from your
vpc private google access or private
service connect can also be configured
so that clients on prem can connect
privately over a hybrid connection to
access a cloud run service
finally there are a few scenarios that
can occur when another google cloud
service needs to send requests to cloud
run
requests from event arc pub sub and
workflows in the same project or vpc
service control perimeter are recognized
as internal and can access cloudrun
directly if the ingress is set to
internal
requests from another cloud run service
app engine and cloud functions in the
same project or vpc service controls
perimeter are recognized as internal
only with the use of a serverless vpc
access connector which we'll talk more
about later requests from other google
cloud services not mentioned cannot use
the internal ingress setting and must
use service specific authentication
however google cloud is continuing to
update the list of services that are
recognized as internal
now let's move on to egress patterns
by default the cloud run service
connects to external endpoints on the
internet using a dynamic ip address poll
meaning cloud run can egress directly
from the application if the destination
is on the internet or public
connectivity is desired
but what if the destination is within
the vpc and requires private
connectivity
this is where you can use a serverless
vpc access connector
requests originating from cloudrun can
connect to sources in the vpc using a
serverless vpc access connector and the
source of the requests would appear as
if they are originating from the
connector
configuring a serverless vpc access
connector for a standard vpc is a simple
process of defining the access connector
for vpc and choosing the subnet in which
the connector will run
there are two different configuration
options for a serverless vpc access
connector for a shared vpc
you can either set up connectors in each
service project that has cloud run
resources that need access to your
network
or you can set up shared connectors in
the host project
there are advantages to each method and
you can check out the docs linked below
for more information the last egress
pattern is through a static outbound ip
as stated before cloud run services
connect to endpoints on the internet
using a dynamic ip address pool but what
happens if you need a single static ip
address in the event you need to connect
to a database or api using an ip address
based firewall
with the use of the previously described
serverless vpc access connector you can
route outbound calls through the vpc
which can then make use of a cloudnat
configured with a static address to
egress through the vpc with a predefined
single ip address
now that we've discussed routing
patterns let's talk about a few ways to
secure cloud run services
make sure to properly configure your
ingress and authentication settings
ingress has the settings to allow all
allow internal and load balancer and
allow internal traffic only
as for authentication you can choose to
allow unauthenticated invocations for
public apis or websites or to require
authentication for which users are
managed through cloud iam
additionally if you are using an
external https load balancer you can
configure identity aware proxy which as
of the date of publication is in preview
as an authentication service as well as
cloud armor as a web application
firewall
so let's summarize the three most
important takeaways from today cloud run
is serverless and does not run within a
vpc
make sure you understand fully the
ingress and egress patterns of your
service to know if you need to set up a
serverless vpc access connector to
connect to applications and services
running within the vpc
set the appropriate ingress control and
authentication settings for the cloud
run service
thanks for watching and look out for
another video on the concepts of
networking for google cloud's managed
services
[Music]